Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Beth, what do you think
about when I say the word octopus?
Well, I know
they're intelligent, they can change
colour to hide in their surroundings,
and of course they have eight arms.
But, I have to admit I also think
about how they taste - delicious.
Yeah, I think that too,
as do plenty of other people. Octopus
is most commonly eaten in South
Korea, Spain, Portugal and Japan,
where they can't get
enough of that umami
flavour. Umami is one of the five
basic tastes and is a savoury flavour.
Until recently octopus
has only been caught in the wild,
but now a Spanish
multinational company has announced
it will be ready
to sell farmed octopus soon,
which campaigners have described as
ethically and ecologically unjustified.
This is because octopuses are sentient,
an adjective describing
a thing that experiences
feelings like pleasure and pain.
Humans and many other animals like pigs,
monkeys and birds are also sentient.
So, is it
OK to farm octopus
when they have been shown to experience
feelings? In this programme,
we'll be discussing whether
farming octopus can ever be ethical
and, as usual,
we will be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first
I have a question for you, Beth.
Octopuses are known
for their ability to problem solve
and when kept in tanks
have been known to escape.
But where did Inky
the octopus go when he broke
out of his tank
at the New Zealand National Aquarium
in 2016?
Was it a) down a drain
into the Pacific Ocean, b)
to the tank of a female octopus, or c)
to the aquarium car park.
I'll guess he went to the tank
of a female octopus.
OK, Beth. I'll reveal the answer later
in the programme. In many countries,
it is not easy to find
octopus in shops,
but if plans for farmed octopus
go ahead, you're much more likely
to see it in the supermarket.
Claire Marshall, who has been
reporting on the octopus farm story
since 2019 explains why
octopuses have not been farmed
before, as she told BBC
World Service programme, The Food
Chain.
They've got an incredibly complex
life cycle
and its, scientists
have been working feverishly
to try to close that life cycle,
particularly in Mexico and Japan,
and obviously now Spain.
They need live food -
the larvae. And also octopuses
are incredibly solitary and
it just makes it really hard to manage
to basically keep them in captivity
at a commercial scale.
Octopuses are difficult to farm
because they have a complex life cycle -
the series of changes
an animal goes through,
starting with birth and
ending with death.
Unlike traditional farmed animals
like chickens
and pigs, who are social animals
and can be kept together,
octopuses are solitary,
meaning they like to live alone.
This makes keeping them in captivity
very difficult because of space.
If an animal lives in captivity, it's
kept somewhere and not allowed to leave,
even if it wants to – like in a zoo.
But it's not only space
that is a problem
when it comes to farming octopus.
It's their capacity
to feel emotions as well.
Scientific researcher doctor
Heather Browning has been studying
the sentience of octopuses for a
British government-commissioned report.
She shared the report findings
with Ruth
Alexander, presenter of BBC
Radio 4 programme,
The Food Chain.
So, we wanted to
look at whether they had
specific kinds of nerve connections
or if they had specific kinds of brains
and whether they were capable
of performing certain kinds of trade-off
behaviours or pain-related behaviours,
learning behaviours
that we thought would correlate
with the probability of sentience.
And what we found for octopuses in
particular is they seemed to meet many
of the criteria
that we'd laid out.
The scientists found that octopuses do
experience feelings because they show
typical characteristics
of sentient creatures, such as trade-off
behaviour. Trade-off
means giving up one thing
in return for another, such
as giving up shelter for food.
So, it looks like the debate about
whether it's OK to farm
and eat octopuses will continue.
OK, Beth. I think it's time
I revealed the answer to my question.
I asked you where Inky
the octopus went when he escaped his
tank at the New Zealand National Aquarium.
And I said it was
to the tank
of a female
octopus.
Well, that was the wrong answer,
I'm afraid.
In fact, Inky
the octopus was trying
to reach the tank of a female
but he found a drain instead, which
led straight to the Pacific Ocean.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we have learned from this programme,
starting with umami,
the flavour octopus has,
which can be described as savoury
and is one of the five basic tastes.
If something is sentient,
it experiences
feelings such as joy and pain.
Life cycle
is the series of changes something
goes through from birth to death.
If something is solitary,
it likes to live alone.
In captivity means
an animal is kept somewhere
and is not allowed to leave.
And finally trade-off
means to exchange
one thing for another.
Once again
our six minutes are up.
Join us again soon for more useful
vocabulary here at Six Minute
English. Goodbye for now.
Bye!